GOTTEN VACCINATED.
IN LESS THAN FOUR MONTHS WE'VE
GONE FROM LESS THAN 6% TO 60% OF
ADULTS IN AMERICA WITH AT LEAST
ONE SHOT.
WE'RE SEEING THE RESULTS IN
LIVE -- IN PEOPLE'S LIVES AND IN
THEIR LIVELIHOODS.
DEATHS ARE DOWN FROM COVID BY
81%.
AND ALSO AT THEIR LOWEST LEVEL
SINCE APRIL OF 2020.
AS A RESULT OF OUR PROMPT ACTION
TO ROLL OUT THE VACCINE AND
BOOST THE ECONOMY, WE'VE GONE
FROM STAGNATION TO AN ECONOMY
THAT IS GROWING FASTER THAN IT
HAS IN NEARLY 40 YEARS.
WE'VE GONE FROM ANEMIC JOB
CREATION TO A RECORD OF CREATION
FOR MORE -- FOR A NEW
ADMINISTRATION, NONE HAS EVER
CREATED THIS MANY JOBS IN THIS
TIME FRAME.
PROGRESS IS UNDENIABLE.
BUT WE'RE NOT DONE YET.
AND SOME OF THE HARDEST WORK IS
AHEAD.
WE'RE STILL LOSING TOO MANY
AMERICANS, AND WE STILL HAVE TOO
MANY UNVACCINATED PEOPLE IN
AMERICA.
LAST WEEK THE CDC ANNOUNCED THAT
IF YOU'RE FULLY VACCINATED, YOU
NO LONGER HAVE TO WEAR A MASK.
IT REPORTED THAT THE SCIENCE NOW
SHOWS THAT YOUR VACCINATION
PROTECTS YOU AS WELL AS BEING
MASKED OR BETTER THAN BEING
MASKED.
SO YOU CAN PROTECT YOURSELF FROM
SERIOUS ILLNESS FROM COVID BY
GETTING VACCINATED.
OR WEARING A MASK UNTIL YOU'RE
FULLY VACCINATED.
EITHER WAY, YOU'RE PROTECTED.
AS I SAID LAST WEEK, SOME PEOPLE
MAY WANT TO CONTINUE TO WEAR A
MASK.
EVEN IF THEY ARE FULLY
VACCINATED.
THAT'S A DECISION THEY CAN MAKE.
SOME BUSINESSES MAY WANT TO
CONTINUE TO REQUIRE WEARING
MASKS.
LET'S ALL BE KIND AND RESPECTFUL
TO ONE ANOTHER AS WE COME OUT OF
THIS PANDEMIC AND RESPECT THOSE
WHO WANT TO CONTINUE TO WEAR A
MASK, EVEN IF THEY'VE BEEN
VACCINATED.
ABOVE ALL, LET'S WORK TOGETHER,
THOUGH, TO MEET THE TARGET, I'VE
SAID, OF 70% OF ADULTS, ALL
ADULTS, WITH AT LEAST ONE SHOT
BY JULY THE 4th.
SEVEN STATES HAVE ALREADY DONE
THIS.
GETTING VACCINATED HAS NEVER
BEEN EASIER.
WE ARE 80,000 LOCATIONS WHERE
YOU CAN GET A SHOT, 90% OF YOU
LIVE WITHIN FIVE MILES OF ONE OF
THOSE LOCATIONS.
YOU CAN NOW FIND A VACCINE SITE
NEAR YOU BY TEXTING YOUR ZIP
CODE TO 438829, 438829.
YOUR ZIP CODE, AND THAT NUMBER.
YOU'LL GET ALL THE PLACES NEAR
YOU, MANY PLACES DON'T REQUIRE
AN APPOINTMENT.
JUST WALK IN AND GET THE SHOT.
IT'S FREE.
AND EVERYONE 12 YEARS AND ABOVE
IS ELIGIBLE.
IF YOU NEED HELP GETTING YOUR
VACCINE SITE -- GETTING TO OR
FROM YOUR VACCINATION SITE, LYFT
AND UBER ARE OFFERING FREE RIDES
TO TAKE YOU TO THE VACCINATION
SITE AND BRING YOU BACK HOME
BETWEEN MAY 24th AND JULY THE
4th.
TO ANYONE WHO WANTS TO GET
VACCINATED.
AND I'VE CALLED ON EMPLOYERS TO
DO THEIR PART AS WELL.
OFFERING THEIR EMPLOYEES PAID
TIME OFF TO GET VACCINATED.
AND WE'VE SET UP A PROGRAM
NATIONALLY TO REIMBURSE THOSE
BUSINESSES FOR THE COST OF
GIVING EMPLOYEES THE TIME OFF.
NOW IT'S TIME TO GET YOUR SHOT.
WE HAVE THE VACCINE.
WE'VE SECURED ENOUGH SUPPLY TO
VACCINATE ALL ADULTS AND
CHILDREN ABOVE THE AGE OF 12.
I REPEAT, NOW'S THE TIME TO GET
YOUR VACCINE SHOT.
NOW, OVER THE PAST 118 DAYS OUR
VACCINATIONS PROGRAM HAS LED THE
WORLD.
AND TODAY WE'RE TAKING AN
ADDITIONAL STEP TO HELP THE
WORLD.
WE KNOW AMERICA WILL NEVER BE
FULLY SAFE UNTIL THE PANDEMIC IS
UNDER CONTROL.
NO OCEAN IS WIDE ENOUGH, NO
WALLS HIGH ENOUGH TO KEEP US
SAFE.
RAMPANT DISEASE AND DEATH IN
OTHER COUNTRIES CAN DESTABILIZE
THEM, AND POSE A RISK TO US AS
WELL.
NEW VARIANTS COULD AS I RISE
OVERSEAS THAT COULD PUT US AT
GREATER RISK AND WE NEED TO HELP
FIGHT THE DISEASE AROUND THE
WORLD TO KEEP US SAFE HERE AT
HOME AND TO DO THE RIGHT THING
OF HELPING OTHER PEOPLE.
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
IT'S THE SMART THING TO DO.
IT'S THE STRONG THING TO DO.
IN MARCH, WE SHARED OVER 4
MILLION DOSES OF OUR ASTRAZENECA
VACCINE WITH CANADA AND MEXICO.
AT THE END OF APRIL, WE
ANNOUNCED THAT WE WOULD PROVIDE
ANOTHER 60 MILLION DOSES OF OUR
ASTRAZENECA VACCINE OVERSEAS.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE VACCINE
THAT'S NOT AUTHORIZED FOR USE IN
THE UNITED STATES YET.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BE SENDING IT
TO FOLKS ONCE THE FDA'S REVIEWED
THIS, AND SAID IT'S SAFE.
THIS IS ALL THE ASTRAZENECA
VACCINE PRODUCED IN THE UNITED
STATES, ALL OF IT WILL BE SENT
TO OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND TODAY I'M ANNOUNCING THAT
WE'LL ALSO SHARE U.S. AUTHORIZED
VACCINE DOSES OF PFIZER AND
MODERNA AND JOHNSON & JOHNSON AS
THEY BECOME AVAILABLE WITH THE
REST OF THE WORLD AS WELL.
THESE ARE VACCINATIONS AND
VACCINES THAT ARE AUTHORIZED TO
BE PUT IN ARMS OF AMERICANS.
AND BY THE END OF JUNE, WHEN WE
WILL HAVE TAKEN DELIVERY OF
ENOUGH OF SUCH VACCINES TO
PROTECT EVERYONE IN THE UNITED
STATES, THE UNITED STATES WILL
SHARE AT LEAST 20 MILLION OF
THOSE DOSES, THAT EXTRA SUPPLY
WITH OTHER COUNTRIES.
THIS MEANS OVER THE NEXT SIX
WEEKS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA WILL SEND 80 MILLION
DOSES OVERSEAS.
THAT REPRESENTS 13% OF THE
VACCINES PRODUCED BY THE UNITED
STATES BY THE END OF JUNE.
THIS WILL BE MORE VACCINES THAN
ANY COUNTRY HAS ACTUALLY SHARED
TO DATE, FIVE TIMES MORE THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTRY.
MORE THAN RUSSIA, CHINA.
WHICH HAVE DONATED 15 MILLION
DOSES.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A LOT OF TALK
ABOUT RUSSIA AND CHINA
INFLUENCING THE WORLD WITH
VACCINES.
WE WANT TO LEAD THE WORLD WITH
OUR VALUES, WITH THIS
DEMONSTRATION OF OUR INNOVATION
AND INGENUITY AND THE
FUNDAMENTAL DECENCY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
JUST AS IN WORLD WAR II, AMERICA
WAS THE ARSENAL OF DEMOCRACY IN
THE BATTLE AGAINST COVID-19
PANDEMIC, OUR NATION IS GOING TO
BE THE ARSENAL OF VACCINES FOR
THE REST OF THE WORLD.
WE'LL SHARE THESE VACCINES IN
THE SERVICE OF ENDING THE
PANDEMIC EVERYWHERE, AND WE WILL
NOT USE OUR VACCINES TO SECURE
FAVORS FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE'LL WORK WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATION SET
UP AND OTHER PARTNERS TO ENSURE
THAT THE VACCINES ARE DELIVERED
IN A WAY THAT IS EQUITABLE AND
THAT FOLLOWS THE SCIENCE AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DATA.
TODAY'S ANNOUNCEMENT TO SHARE 80
MILLION DOSES IS OUR NEXT STEP
AS WE RAMP UP THE EFFORTS TO
RESPOND TO COVID-19 AROUND THE
WORLD.
IN THE WEEKS AHEAD WORKING WITH
THE WORLD'S DEMOCRACIES WE'LL
COORDINATE A MULTILATERAL EFFORT
TO END THIS PANDEMIC.
I EXPECT TO ANNOUNCE PROGRESS IN
THIS AREA AT THE G-7 SUMMIT IN
THE UNITED KINGDOM IN JUNE WHICH
I PLAN ON ATTENDING.
THIS IS A UNIQUE MOMENT IN
HISTORY, AND IT REQUIRES
AMERICAN LEADERSHIP.
BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR, BEING IN
THIS PANDEMIC GLOBALLY IS BEYOND
THE CAPACITY OF ANY ONE NATION,
INCLUDING THE UNITED STATES.
THE UNITED STATES WILL CONTINUE
TO DONATE OUR EXCESS SUPPLY AS
THAT SUPPLY IS DELIVERED TO US,
BUT THAT WON'T BE NEARLY ENOUGH.
WE NEED -- WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
LEAD AN ENTIRELY NEW EFFORT, AN
EFFORT THAT INVOLVES WORKING
WITH THE PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES AND OTHERS, AND
PARTNER NATIONS TO VASTLY
INCREASE SUPPLY, TO CREATE MOST
OF IT HERE IN THE UNITED STATES,
THE KIND OF CAPACITY THAT CAN
BEAT THIS PANDEMIC WORLDWIDE, IN
A WAY THAT CREATES JOBS HERE AT
HOME, AND SAVES LIVES ABROAD.
THIS WILL TAKE LONGER THAN OUR
IMMEDIATE WORK TO DONATE FROM AN
EXISTING SUPPLY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE ASKING
OTHER NATIONS TO HELP SHOULDER
THE ECONOMIC COST OF THIS
EFFORT.
BUT THE CONSEQUENCES WILL BE
MORE LASTING AND MORE DRAMATIC.
DOING THIS WILL HELP US BEAT THE
PANDEMIC.
AND LEAVE US WITH A
MANUFACTURING CAPACITY HERE TO
PREPARE FOR THE NEXT CRISIS, THE
NEXT VACCINE NEEDED.
I'M PUTTING JEFF ZIENTS WHO'S
LEESING OUR COVID TEAM AND THE
COVID EFFORTS TO BEAT THE VIRUS
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES IN
CHARGE OF THIS EFFORT.
JEFF WILL BE WORKING WITH OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL AND A
TALENTED DEDICATED TEAM THAT'S
BEEN STOOD UP ACROSS OUR
GOVERNMENT.
INCLUDING GAIL SMITH IN THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND EXPERTS
FROM OUR AGENCY OF INTERNATIONAL
DEPARTMENT AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AS
WELL.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THE SAME
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT RESPONSE TO
THE GLOBAL EFFORT THAT MADE US
SO SUCCESSFUL HERE AT HOME.
AGAIN, WE HAVE ENOUGH -- WE
HAVE -- WE, THE UNITED STATES,
HAS SECURED ENOUGH SUPPLY FOR
ALL ELIGIBLE AMERICANS, ALL
AMERICANS 12 YEARS OLD AND OLDER
AND WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO
THOUGH.
HARD WORK.
BUT BECAUSE WE HAVE DONE SO MUCH
HERE, BECAUSE OF THE POWER OF
AMERICAN COMPANIES RESEARCH AND
MANUFACTURING WE CAN CONTINUE TO
DO MORE TO HELP THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
THIS IS A RAPIDLY CHANGING
AND IT'S A MISTAKE TO BET
AGAINST DEMOCRACIES.
JUST AS DEMOCRACIES LED THE
WORLD IN THE DARKNESS OF WORLD
WAR II, DEMOCRACY WILL LEAD THE
WORLD OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC AND
AMERICA WILL LEAD THOSE
DEMOCRACIES AS THEY WORK TO
BRING GREATER HEALTH AND HOPE TO
THE WORLD IN THE MONTHS TO COME.
AND FOLKS, THINK BACK, FOUR
MONTHS AGO, FOUR MONTHS AGO WAS
AN AUDACIOUS GOAL WE HAD TO PUT
A MILLION SHOTS IN THE ARMS OF
MY FIRST HUNDRED DAYS AS
PRESIDENT, 100 MILLION I SHOULD
SAY.
WE DID OVER 220 MILLION SHOTS IN
THAT TIME FRAME.
BACK THEN MOST ADULTS WEREN'T
ELIGIBLE TO GET THE SHOT.
NOW EVERYONE 12 YEARS AND OLDER
IS ELIGIBLE.
AND TOMORROW -- BY TOMORROW, 60%
OF ALL AMERICAN ADULTS WILL HAVE
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE SHOT.
LOOK WHAT WE'VE DONE.
LOOK WHAT WE'VE DONE, AMERICA.
LOOK WHAT YOU'VE DONE, AMERICA.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE THING
BEYOND OUR CAPACITY TO DO IN
THIS COUNTRY, AND WE'LL DECIDE
TO DO IT TOGETHER.
WE CAN DO WHATEVER WE SET OUR
MINDS TO DO IF WE DO IT
TOGETHER.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO.
SOLVE THE PROBLEM HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, WHICH WE'RE WELL
ON O